Ukraine is restricting the use of
electricity for the first time since
Russia invaded in February that comes
after power plants were repeatedly hit
by Russian missiles and drones President
Vladimir zielinski says Russia has
destroyed a third of Ukraine's power
stations in just one week of Muhammad
James live for us in Kiev and people are
being asked to conserve energy so can
you explain what restrictions have been
put in place today
Tom this is a very significant
Announcement by government officials
today when it comes to the Restriction
of electricity going forward let me
first tell you a little bit more of what
we heard from Ukrainian President
Vladimir zielinski and his nightly
address last night he said that we are
preparing for all kinds of scenarios in
view of the winter season he went on to
say we do not exclude that with the
onset of the cold weather we will be
asking for your help even more
frequently really underscoring the
concern of officials here over the
course of the past couple of weeks since
so much energy infrastructure has been
damaged or destroyed by oncoming Russian
missiles or these drones that were
attacking in the last few days as well
many officials over the course of the
past 48 hours have been repeating the
line that citizens must also do more to
prepare themselves for the winter
I must tell you just from yesterday to
today the temperature has dropped
precipitously so it really goes to show
that people are worried that it is just
going to be getting colder because
winter hasn't really started here yet
now as far as the restrictions that have
been announced this is the first time
that these Nationwide restrictions have
been put in place since Russia's
invasion in February the power supply is
to be restricted between 7 A.M and 11 pm
daily there may be temporary blackouts
if people don't comply with these
restrictions and don't try to conserve
on their uh to conserve energy
consumption and I will tell you that
what we've been told is that shopkeepers
restaurant owners business owners have
been told they need to keep the lights
off in the evening also modes of public
transportation some of them will be
suspended and we also got an
announcement by the mayor of Kiev in
which he said this is Vitali Klitschko
he asked residents in the capital not to
use major electrical appliances he said
said that even saving and reducing
electricity consumption in each
residence in each household is going to
help stabilize the national Energy
Systems Operations so pretty drastic
restrictions are being put in place
what's been the reaction from ukrainians
are they behind this
well Tom everybody we've been speaking
with in the neighborhoods that have been
impacted by power outages after either
missile strikes or drone strikes these
past few days have told us that they are
worried that it is going to get worse
and that they are preparing themselves
as best they can a couple of days ago we
went out to destinyansky District that's
east of the capital here it's one of
kiev's districts that was an area where
a power infrastructure was hit by
Russian missiles and those residents
told us that this was the second week in
a row that they had been impacted by
power outage is that being said they
were back online just hours later and
that's something that we've seen a lot
the past couple of weeks is typically
the power grid in those impacted areas
they're quick to repair them enough so
that energy isn't impacted that much now
there is concern that it is only going
to get worse we have also spoken to
Residents in other parts of the country
in which they said they don't think the
government has done enough to prepare
the cities and to prepare the citizens
and that more infrastructure needs to be
protected and the more measures need to
be put in place so that if there are
more power outages residents have access
to heated areas and they have access to
energy going forward Tom okay Muhammad
Jim June for us alive in cave thank you